you were like take it no take it or
leave it or off that's how you've lived
your whole
life yeah but until yeah but not I
wouldn't say off as much now no no no no
no I'm saying like you would you were
just you like you didn't give a [__] if
somebody like like it just didn't matter
bro like for me I'm I was like much more
diplomatic like I wanted to like
manipulate people into whatever is going
to make me
whatever is going to get me what I want
from them but yeah and I was much more
like if you don't like what I'm saying
you can go straight yourself hard so who
who's the older brother here I'm the
older brother by a year yeah when you're
older a year and a couple months same
parents yep Mom and Dad same mom and dad
same mom and dad yep
yeah so Kenny you uh you you grew up
with Daniel yep in uh where are you guys
from V Venice right here in St and your
parents were
were together till I was 10 so you were
nine no I was six so Dad you were seven
or eight you were seven promise you that
cuz Pat was three he who who who was uh
a bigger problem for you guys your mom
or dad mom mom D mom's but but Mom I and
I think I mean I believe Daniel is more
accepting of this as well like she
suffers from severe mental illness so
like I don't take any of it personal but
it wasn't pleasant you know like she was
she was out there she was I mean she she
had cocaine she had a cocaine addiction
and Al and like Jack Daniels of Rocka so
like that combination is going to be a
guaranteed bipolar disaster disaster I
remember white coats taking her out bro
into penguin [__] white coat draging
it seems it seems like these drugs I've
seen people up dude Florida they bring
out the schizophrenia or the or the
whatever mental illness yeah bipolar 2
maybe her dad went missing though
remember yeah he's named after our
grandfather that we never met cuz he
went missing when my mom was young he
like was smuggling cocaine from the
Florida Keys to Panama so that's the
story and he just never came back one
time like on his third trip he just
never come back so we were told so Mom
got [__] up off that I was told that
[__] her up we were told at a young
Agee that he was um Mia he was he was
MIA he was a Merchant Marine and he was
MIA [__] bro that was [__] SL
cocaine dog no I know oh
yeah so we were told at a young age that
he was a Merchant Marine and he went MIA
I do okay but then she she hid her
drinking when she was with my dad
because they were you know she was
really into like religion and stuff but
like which I I have spiritual I think
spirituality is a beautiful thing but
organ her organized like religion like I
feel that
people some people with mental illness
are very drawn towards specific
denominational religion so she was
really into that so she hid her drinking
so it was like you know her and like she
took pills too remember her she was
prescribed like valum and she had like
seven kids bro so yeah so she kids I
remember like one of like one of our
friends in elementary school being like
saying like like your mom smells like
Uncle D Uncle Joey like later on we come
to find out like Uncle Joey's a drunk
you know so but then like later when she
leaves my dad like in a like she left
him for a reason she it was like midlife
crisis like let her freak flag fly
that's watch like with my Uncle Jerry
cuz he was a nut you know you tell me
about your Uncle Jerry he was he was
wild oh he's [__] nuts D yeah yeah he
was [__] nuts you know what he was so
crazy this is how twisted this dude was
he would literally say [__] stop
yelling at my brother's kids to my mom
yeah Pat once called him Uncle dad you
said that in another video and it's
weird yeah that's weird as [__] because
our cousins were like you know like
first cousins they're like we're not
brother sister but they were older they
were really good to us our older cousins
hi and Jeremy [__] looked out and
Brian looked out for his tough they
looked out for his tough because they
knew it was all twisted they were
teenagers they're like this is all bad
you know like well he was like a fall
drink down drunk and like weird and they
would fight but he was always kind to us
us yeah he never
ever stepped in line with us ever he was
so sweet to us he had problems with law
and problems with yeah yeah yeah he was
an outlaw for sure 100% he was so
cocaine out of Marco polos it was an old
Pizza like pizza shop SLB bar at the top
of Tanga and he him and only place back
then too it was like when we would like
stay with her in summers like that I I
don't know why but that's like it was
like the I think that was like the only
place or you had to go down to the
valley or down to the PCH there was like
Marco Polo's pizza and so yeah I guess
that was before like the the like um at
the bar up there do you remember when he
was a what did he called Trav travel
agent dude dude the dude had two I swear
to God he had two pistols that they were
nickel plated they look like Chrome and
he had them and he wore a suit this dude
had one eye bro like and long red hair
and a ponytail right so my dad has eight
like there's eight boys and two girls so
they were all these brothers that were
like you know half of them were gnarly
the other half were like kind of not
they were squares you know and um and uh
so um he' be he showed up in his the
Mercedes he was working for that
landlord that he pulled out of the
jacuzzi and put the pistol to his head
he was like what' you [__] dude he
can't yeah he pulled the landlord out of
the jacuzzi by his hair put the pistol
in his face I was like who do you think
you're [__] talking to dumb rich
mother [__] yeah he's like yeah nuts
that was nuts bro yeah that was nuts we
were kids and like our mom's inside like
stay inside like in the window like
watching him piss with our landlord
we're living in the pool
house on he was like living on the
property like that's how he paid his
rent was like as like a landske keeper
and like the guy was like drunk one day
in the jacuzzi and he was like hollering
at him like like Jerry come on fun
F do and he's like no stop what you do
and come now he like he was his boss or
some [__] and that did not work with M
Jerry mon Jerry ran from the cops on
Horseback in LA in LA county like what
do you [__] what do you mean like cuz
like the elementary school has these
like dividers like those things that
stop cars from going around theate gate
to get in that LCI school so like my
cousins and everybody knew you just on a
dirt bike or a horse you can just tuck
into that that walkway and the cops
can't what are they going to do and you
can get they knew the Canyons like the
back of their hand they were born and
raised there you know I mean my cousins
were my uncle they're all born and
raised in
Venice M my whole family we've been out
here for over 100 years my grandma died
in 99 last year yeah so so this talk is
mainly with Kenny my bad but but I
couldn't resist putting hutch in a chair
next to you cuz because you guys
together are fun to listen to thanks for
reminding me no feel feel free to chime
in all you like no but but so Kenny you
you working treatment now yes so you
guys both got involved in
drugs together or different
times you guys you guys started around
the same time with drugs or yeah yeah I
was I mean uh he was real young when he
went to the military so we were drinking
I always drank heavily when I drank but
like I was always under the impression
just like anybody else like if you don't
show up to like work drunk then you're
not you're just a kid having fun and and
and at that time it really was like
there was always but what I realized was
is that we
weren't or I don't think we were like
everybody else we didn't have one group
of friends we had 20 or 30 groups of
friends so what I could do is like oh
like everybody's taking it easy
in this group in this group in this oh
they're partying so it didn't matter
Monday through Sunday there was always
somewhere to go where I could where we
could get lit
so yeah and I I remember my sister once
like crying like like you drink too much
and I'm like I got a job I got money in
the bank I don't know what you're
talking about but it was a lot you know
I would drink it by the gallons and I
would and I would do like
a you know to to be honest I was
thinking about it when when we were
talking
earlier he that is one good thing that
he prompts me on is it's hard for me to
remember yeah because I mean between the
the pills and the cocaine or the
whatever I remember for a while there
was meth that was Hawaii too though
right Hawaii definitely he lived in
Hawaii before I did like years before I
did yeah Hawaii I went to Hawaii to get
sober and they came back like dying bro
dying so much methodone like there was
like flies on him it was so bad my dad
was like don't let my kid die yeah and
then I got you in treatment yeah I was I
was I was
uh I was pretty wild and and I was doing
like pretty much anything to keep the
party going so it didn't matter if it
was like pill you I just thought of
something that happened that was so
weird in Venice so there was this little
bar we would go to and it was a local
hangout and we liked it because um they
weren't real strict about carding back
then um so
start no no no no no that one you could
get lost in the crowd or slip on a 100
no this was the other one uh over uh in
like uh is that Culver City over over on
that side Washington
side um
so I was God I think it was there I it
could have been it could have been
Culver City at that dirty Dive Bar
anyways I meet this
chick and we're partying
and
so I'll tell the story in order of the
way it happened so next thing I know I'm
in her room things are getting good I'm
in she I'm I'm you know being a lazy ass
I'm all [__] up on my back she's in
full Mountain doing the work and she
[__] something we were doing a lot of
blow that night but her [__]
eyes flipped
like something happened and a different
person appeared almost as if she jumped
off and a new girl jumped on but it she
never did that and
she comes up over me and I'm
in sex is great when they're on top and
all but you're also very vulnerable you
just don't realize it CU you're so
[__] pleasurable but you actually are
in a very vulnerable position you would
never want a man sitting on I mean I
mean I mean if there's men that want to
do that that's cool but I'm talking
about like compromis in a violent
situation worst case scenario their
Mount they got their legs on top of you
like this and you're on the bottom and
she just starts gunning me
and I'm just and I'm in full guard and
I'm trying to Buck her off and I'm like
and finally like I get her
off I run out the door so she was right
off Speedway so this is like Venice
Beach beach yeah right that's alley
behind
the this old black guy smoking a blunt
he's like oh PCP is a [__] and I
look and I realize I'm [__] butt
naked so I'm like I got to go back like
I'm definitely not doing I'm definitely
not like LAPD is not hearing any story
of me butt naked and a girl beat me up
during sex so like I got to get my
clothes wallet keys everything's in
there so I go back she's in the fetal
position in the corner of the room I
swear to God I didn't do anything to her
like this was a normal transaction of uh
two human beings trying to have a
beautiful moment [__] up out of their
mind you know what I mean like I didn't
say nothing to her I'm I'm not kinky I
wasn't like you dirty little girl I
wasn't calling her my daughter like
nothing weird happened I'm not a vocal
like sexual person so I don't know what
happened with in that situation but I
come back and I'm just like you can go
talk to a therapist talk to whoever you
want I'm gonna give my [__] I'm gonna go
the old black guy reminded me I'm naked
so I hope all is good with whatever you
got going on with you
so my birthday comes around and we're
hanging out with a couple of people I'm
not sure if you were there or not you
know uhh five years in my like five
years in my 20s were wiped fresh was
there and and and a couple other people
and she darkens my door what does that
and I was like she appears at the
[__] door and we had like an open
door policy cuz it was party whenever I
wasn't working I always worked always
even sometimes like I would also do side
jobs and stuff like that so 10 12 hours
sometimes and then I would drink myself
to sleep like drinking was
necessary but is this when you live next
door to Pat yes yeah so we live next
door to each other at one point like me
and my little brother Pat and then Kenny
so three full-blooded Brothers all lived
in one apartment building on the top and
then my cousin lived downstairs my first
cousin lived downstair yeah this was at
that place on yep yep yep and place was
fun and uh she shows up at the I'm like
oh my God and I'm hiding right in a room
full of guns I always had guns on me I
was like I would carry I have a
possession of deadly weapons charge like
I would I just I he like guns I
personally now that I'm sober I won't
like I I want to get my CCW I want to do
it legally I'm not going to illegally
carry a firearm I I've learned that
there's consequences for everything that
you do in life good or bad but at that
that time gun time I was pissed off it
was G play because I wasn't trying like
I had got my head beat in before I
wasn't trying to have that happen again
like I I gave a sloppy anyways let me
finish this story so this chick shows up
and we have this friend and she's Prett
pretty gnarly and she sees me run and
hide in my room and she's like what and
this girl's like got balloons and
flowers and looks all sweet and she's
like Kenny what the [__] is wrong with
you I was like tell that [__] to get
the [__] out of the house you got to get
rid of her and so she like goes over
there and she's like oh that's weird I
don't know why I just wanted to drop
this off her I'm like how the [__] and
then I
realized from the bar to her house I
stopped at the house to get blow so
whether it messes with your mind or it's
just a part of the scenario stimulants
make everything weird like everything
gets weird when there stimulant yo meth
will [__] some [__] up dude meth will
[__] some [__] up I shot meth one time
and started shooting at AK through my
walls in Hawaii boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom the neighbors were like you
got to [__] stop dude you know what I
mean yeah they're like babysitting my
son before we stepped in here you were
telling a story about meth and the girl
in in treatment oh yeah working in
working in substance abuse is the best
and worst job you can have so if you
want to help people it's a best job in
the world if you're doing it for money
nobody ever makes it it's it's the most
God
awful horrible job you could ever have
so it just it all depends on your
intentions like what what what are you
in it for but yeah no he's talking about
this specific yeah yeah so we I've got
lots of stories like that I've been
working for almost a decade in treatment
she's just one of them but yeah she she
comes she get she comes in She's heite
Like You Can Tell She's been smoking m
I'm thinking for years right like like
I'm getting this chick for years and
she's [__] me [__] me she's like who's
gonna [__] me here and she's running
around and she's like if I'm not going
to get any dick like throwing tantrum if
I'm not going to get any dick then you
can I'm not [__] staying here and so
well you know and you just have to keep
talking to him like no I can't give you
any dick like but obviously a lot more
therapeutically but you're like you're
like no then no come on you're here for
reason we want we want to make things
better for you blah blah
blah none of these little [__] are
gonna give me some dick and so I'm like
I'm like no none of these little [__]
are gonna give you some dick let's get
this going let's get come on let's like
let's get this process going and so
finally she's like [__] this and she
walks out the gate goes across the
street sits down on the curb and just
starts
finger I'll do it my set up
what part of
town south central oh jeez white half
naked white girl a white girl in a tough
yeah Central uh 33rd and
Central yeah right off the 10 like
you're I mean San Pedro's right there in
the mix in the mix it's it's it's it's
not suggested we had another
guy we had another guy he was he was
great he he takes off his shirt he had
been to prison and he's got swastikas on
his
chest and he leaves because you know
he's angry about something and that
sounds like such a bad idea he leaves he
well he wasn't from this state but I
mean like you a lot of people have seen
boys in the hood and like I mean it's
like that's where you are that's you're
in those movies and it's not of course
those movies aren't an exact depiction
of of it and things have gotten
different you know but he goes he leaves
and he's walking around the block cuz he
doesn't know where he is and he just
keeps circling the block and finally
somebody talks him into coming back in
and we have this long deep talk about
trying to get him to stay and save his
life and stuff like that and I was like
bro seriously I'm trying to tell you
like outside of all the other stuff
right you you know you know a lot of
people will go to treatment so many
times they've heard it all they've seen
it all they're also just like they're
like I know you want me to stay and
you're going to tell me it's for my life
and like you know they've heard
thousands of different people say
thousands of different things sadly
people will really go that many times
that's common but this guy
said I was like dude promise me you're
not g to go out
there again like let's get this figured
out right and he's like oh no no don't
don't worry on one of my laps there was
a young African-American gentleman that
let me know real quick that if I'm lost
I better find my way
home because I'm not welcome here at
night he had that coming he had that
that was the nicest thing somebody could
have done for him bro yeah no no I think
I'm honest to God I believe this guy cuz
there was I think a murder right on that
corner like the week before or something
I honestly think that guy was like
trying to help him trying to help him
yeah like he's like I'm from around here
and you're not going to make it far
you're obviously not yeah you're
obviously not from around brother yeah
or this this like you know world yeah
like yeah what in the [__] is wrong with
you like people have grandparents that
like or my dad's dad fought against
Nazis who would [__] be born here and
get his FAS get tattooed him well that's
just a culture of jail and prison you
know yeah yeah but at the same time like
that's that's a stretch right yeah I
wouldn't well okay I'm just conceding to
this don't run around yeah at least get
them done when you're done with that I
guess when you get out fix please Public
Announcement yes do not walk around
South troll is on your [__] it's I mean
I wouldn't advise it no is it is it
easier for you guys like getting clean
together or you know at a similar well I
it was definitely easier for me to get
clean because was already there yeah but
like I was clean when he needed help you
know what I mean so I had had a couple
years and then I dragged his ESS in a
treatment and I remember he's like as
long as I don't have to do any of that
AA cult [__] and then he ended up
becoming like you know he going in a and
really doing well in that program you
did really well in that I didn't say
that as long as they don't make me do
any of that a c [__] and then he
just like totally Twisted that around
got off the drve at one point when my
sister cried I went to an AA meeting I
asked someone that's like oh there's a
young people's meeting at the at Hill
Street right so this is eight years or
nine eight seven or eight years before I
actually give it a real attempt like
through a program and following any
instruction like I said I went to Hawaii
to get off dope on my own but this was
after that but I went to the young
people's meeting and there's this guy
and there's people skating outside and
it was very clicky and everybody knew
each other and was hugging each other
and I'm super anxious and I've gone like
24 hours without a drink I didn't have
DTS or anything like that but my anxiety
was through the roof I don't know any of
these people and the guy up there is
talking about sucking dick for crack and
I was
like I think this isn't for me because
at that time nothing had gotten too
weird little cocaine though no cocaine
get you suck in some
dick Y what did we used to call it go
it's not gay if you're meth yeah it's
not gay it's not gay if we would we
called it that we didn't say
that no no it's not like we parti it's
not I I don't believe that like I
believe that if you are on meth and you
do um if you you do homosexual acts I
don't think I think the meth brought it
out of you you know because I think
people are boring with those Tendencies
I don't I like I have never hit the pipe
and been like man sucking some dick
where be right now or letting some man
suck my dick I've been in positions
where that was the thing like dudes were
like yo or an old man in Hawaii was like
yo here's the deal and I'm like no I'm
cool with that bro you know what I mean
I'll be I'll be sick they call it queer
juice in prison yeah yeah and on the
East Coast yeah yeah that's
weird sorry no no no oh what was I
thinking of hey remember the time at the
mlin apartment when um you were so you
were all drunk and those kids in the
alley like came at you sideways and they
poured on a Venice Boulevard and you
shot at him and a Kim dude we had this
nice lady named Kim that lived
downstairs from us she went out there
and picked up all the shells and then
like put him back inside and flush his
shells on the toilet and like told the
cops yeah some dude R you know some dude
was shooting at these kids ran by like
she cover the whole [__] thing she
was so dope I was coming from was [__]
face but I was coming from somewhere and
there was these guys like blocking the
alleys and some like essays and I was
like honk get the [__] out of the way
and they like gang bang you were wasted
though bro yo yeah yeah yeah and they
were like gang banging on me and I I'm
like and so I just drove at them and
they dive out in front of the car my
this alley was a deadend alley and so
they watched me Park you know as I I
just tried to run them down with my
truck I pull into a spot that's in
vision of them and I go up and I'm I
don't know I must have been out of my
[__] did you have it on you or did you
have to go upstairs and I had it on me I
go in the house I take
my gun and throw it on the couch and go
outside to have a cigarette and they
come
rounding the sidewalk on the V Boulevard
and one of them pulls a gun on me pulls
a gun and I was just like you're not
gonna shoot and that's all I got out
boom boom bom bom bom bom boom and so I
hit the I'm pretty sure you shot at him
first bro I go retrieve my weapon I
forgot and I just [__] reach it was
like there's a the walkway thing it was
all in selfdefense there was like a
walkway like wall thing and I just like
it wasn't like an action movie or
anything like that I just like put it
over the edge and just started like
shoting in case there were you know any
so everybody disperses but yeah there
was this sweet awesome woman that was
she had never forget her bro she like
bro she was like a crack addict in the
80s and [__] and she was clean got her
life together she was she was Raising
her kids in there and [__] her she was
digging slugs out of the ground she took
all the brass put in flush it down the
toilet she's like go go to the bar go
get lost you know we'll tell the cops it
was a shooting out here she was totally
and I did I went down to the bar and I
got drunk till they kicked me out and I
came home and nothing came of
it cocaine's a hell of a drug yeah that
was I mean
drinking drinking was was really
dangerous because as much as it helped
with my panic disorder it also you know
you've got no inhibitions especially if
it's just you just go for it you know I
remember one time I was shitfaced you
were the one that was like you stopped
me I'm pretty sure you're freshly back I
got a sniper rifle out on the that same
had a terce it was like a Terrace that
like got us on and I've got that same
canister and I'm looking down the scope
I just [__] based I I don't even think I
was taking any drugs I was just drunk
and I'm W and I'm looking and this scope
was great it was like a 32 or something
like that it would had a really far
distance and I'm looking our we're on a
major boulevards and their side streets
that go down I'm looking down those side
streets at pedestrians and putting
crosshairs on them and I'm like boom
boom and I wasn't sociopathic I wasn't
actually I didn't even have a round
chamber probably after you broke up with
somebody you're probably in a bad place
mentally you know that was like you
really got like that but what you were
weird with Firearms yeah but you you
came out and you were like what the
[__] there was times that like there
was times we had to ask him not to bring
a gun like don't bring a gun like when
me and kangy the cat me and kangy the
cat were together at his apartment and
we're like bri please don't bring your
gun CL he's like don't I don't want to
be around a gun right now
and you want me to tell the whole story
can I can I [__] it okay so he he's like
I promise and he's wasted he's like I
promise I won't bring you again I love
you guys I respect you guys I know what
you've been through I promise goes in
his bedroom puts a 45 in his waist and
comes back outside if we don't see it we
think we believe him and we're going
down the stairs and he's wearing Dicky
shorts and they're all
baggy and the fing gun no joke it's like
the three of us and we're like flanking
down the stairs and the gun no joke
falls through his [__] shorts dude
and is tumbling end over end down the
stairs and me and Ken like against the
walls like oh my [__] God you piece
you son of a [__] dude and then Kang's
like I'm not going out with you guys
he's I'm not going out with you guys
tonight he did but um he did though he
did you put it away we made like I
walked him minut like you're putting the
gun in the safe you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that yeah that was scary he was
like fumbling after it he was like
trying to and it's like tumbling and
like and he's on it like bro I was so
scared that [__] gun was going to go
off yeah that happens to people you know
like with I'm I wasn't you know we
gotten a lot of scraps but I'm not
classically trained or anything like
that and I don't know a lot of people's
experience my experience with fighting
is you lose some and you win some like
like sometimes it was a domination and
sometimes I would get my head beat in so
that was the great equalizer you know
what I mean like what do they say about
Samuel Colt God made men and Samuel Colt
made equal yeah he did that's what it
was you know you could flash a piece or
just take it out I mean they got the
brandishing laws because of that but
like at that time you shot at people
yeah you shot people I mean but if if
you're getting drunk and getting but
you're not like that now you know what I
mean like there's people that stay stuck
in that kind of [__] bro no no now I
have a completely different look on
Firearms I I respect them I love them
and I also believe that gun safety is
like so important and essential and I
think it should be taught to everybody
you know because it's a it's a right and
so everybody should know about it but
like back then it was just like that it
I mean even getting drunk and
loaded couldn't fully I never felt fully
safe or secure at any time in my life
there was never a time that I felt safe
or secure can I ask you
something what's the worst thing what is
like the worst part of having what is
the worst thing to deal with while
working in treatment what's the like the
the what are the
downsides like because a lot of people
don't even realize how big that industry
is how like gnarly it is how people stay
stuck in it like all that weird [__] you
know like people live in treatment for
years and then people that need it can't
get it because of like the way that the
system is work well the way that the
system works is this so you have you
have your options you there has private
insurance right in that case you're
going to go to a place they're going to
beg you to stay and they're going to beg
you and they're going to want you to
stay and they're going to want you to do
you know they're going to want you to go
through the process and and everything
like that and in that world the private
insurance companies actually run that
world so it's like if you're going to
one of those places they dictate the
terms right they want specific like um
treatment when I went to treatment it
was popular that it was a 90-day program
and it was very popular that it was
abstinence-based right when you say
popular you mean that's easiest to get
paid for it that you could yeah yeah
yeah you would get reimbursed for 90
days and um and and uh abstinence-based
right so and now it's turned to as short
as possible and get them on as much
medication as possible and then people
like you you're you are subject to what
the insurance companies
require to pay out and you're still
ending up in this constant Battle of
fighting with all your might and all
your documentation and everything you
can do to
get that insurance company to pay to pay
yeah Fu so hard you it's it's so they
dictate the terms of treatment so so it
keeps changing yeah so if a doctor comes
you know a doctor is making a thousand
bucks a visit or 500 bucks a visit
depending on like where you are or
whatever like
that I mean what they believe
in and what they got to do to make that
insurance pay might be different and
that's how it goes if you're working in
treatment and people talk about the a
substance abuse epidemic and you and
it's the same systemic problem in sub
substance abuse as anything else
anything else that's nuanced in human um
politics religion it doesn't matter like
the negative side is the you know is
that you are subject to the payer right
like like that's that's it and then you
got your medical stuff right there's a
300 person waiting list ain't nobody
kissing anybody's ass you come in there
and act a fool they'll be like get
they'll physically throw your ass out
because they got you're you have very
little value your your value
is there's 200 people waiting in line to
take your place and it becomes very
hard at any level especially now that
I've gotten into to this level where
it's macroscopic and I have to oversee
all the pieces moving and make sure that
they work in perfect concert to give the
best possible treatment for the person
while still maintaining a profit margin
but you can see it doesn't matter if you
stick with it long
enough you have to work very hard for
human life to not be devalued
it has to be very you see thousands of
people I've I have met and worked with
personally so many people that have
overdosed and died I was going to say
how many like if you were to throw a
like a ballark number bro sto I stopped
counting at 83 that was back in 2017
what what percentage of the people that
are in treatment actually get now the
fentel here too bro oh yeah well that's
that's the thing too is so there's
multiple sides to like substance abuse
in my opinion I mean this is just from
experience that's that's all I have to
go off of but I've seen thousands and
thousands of
people you've got people for
psychological reasons you got people for
physiological reasons you got people for
sociological or existential reasons
right so either they're uh real lucky
and they become physically addicted to
that to that substance and if you can
comfortably make them not physically
addicted to it they're okay that's the
luckiest class there's psychological
where that now you've got this person
and that's where you get into like
that's what you were talking about
earlier I found out I come to find out
that I was anodic that's what had
happened to me like they found me there
was flies on my face I wasn't showering
I didn't I didn't care I was anadon so
you have to have a certain amount of
dopamine just to put on your shoes in
the morning it's the reward center that
like tells you to put one foot in for in
front of the other if you get lots of
that dopamine it's telling you this is
really good this is really really good
you need more of this so that would be
like sugars and stuff you know like
anthropologically speaking like way back
in the day if somebody tasted something
that was rich in Sugar that was rare it
would give them a dopam mean Rush Sex
obviously to to continue the procreation
of the earth you know but then you've
got these substances that dump all of it
at once it is and that's why people say
we close to the great right no you can't
becoming anod like people will throw
around the word anadon like to the
complete depletion of of dopamine like
it's some sort of like common occurrence
it's not that your B your brain can
produce
so we're me that's we're literally phys
physiologically made to make as much
dopamine as we need but I was when I
went to Hawaii I get on methadone and my
personal opinion on methodone is that's
a federally subsidized substance I think
it's a great program but it has nothing
to do with
helping it helping the person is a
byproduct I think it was a crime
reduction idea by the federal government
like if we can you know it's it's kind
of like in like I think Great Britain
was doing it for a while but theyed
methodone right or is it made by the
nais to like come off of
like meth for sure I'm not sure about
because when they would yeah because
when they would like Blitz Creed they're
all hyped up on drugs so then they have
to have a drug to bring them down so
they can sleep you know so I was told
that I like to believe that because
that's an evil [__] substance yeah but I
mean yeah I mean if it's a difference
between someone crawling through your
window and taking your [__] TV or not
sure it's a great thing it's a great
thing but I was on a super yeah over
high dose I was buying people's take
homes and I really was staying away from
everything else like I really did get on
methodone to stop everything
but methadone has an opioid effect
that's serious opioid effect and so
every time forever yeah op yeah
methadone is the only drug that I've
ever heard of that actually gets into
your bone marrow so that means the new
blood that your body makes actually
makes it with Methadone in it because
methodone has some stupid halflife of
like 14 days or something when I went to
treatment I was sober for four days
before I started feeling detox symptoms
and I felt detox symptoms for 45 days
Jesus Christ so you remember you were
doing like a you had to like do your
like counseling sessions in the jacuzzi
because you were wiggling so bad he had
like he was like he was like and then
you had that seizure I was going to beat
up the nurse cuz this was at the
treatment center I worked at that I met
Jack yeah he got me that I met Jack you
know I mean so I got him in there same
treatment center and um we like um I was
going to say his name [__] the rehab
Mogul the guy was so bad but so what
happened was is my brother has a [__]
he's out there hugging a tree no joke
he's hugging a tree cuz he's like as
long as I why were you huging a tree I
felt like it was going to like ground me
cuz I was shaking so bad and he was
having borderline seizures bro like
going in like it was bad he was I did
have one Grand Mall seizure yeah and he
hit his head on the [__] stucco and
I'm like so I look into his Med file and
I'm like my brother's getting 30
milligrams of funeral
barbal and this like 110 pound chick
that says she slams him Grandma heroin a
day of black tar
and does a little meth is getting like
90 and my brother just had a [__]
seizure and hit his head on a stucco
dude I was like remember they had a
remove they removed me from the site
because I was like bugging out bro I was
going to go [__] nuts the nurse I was
like calling his blowing his phone up
threatening his life and [__] I was like
yeah and the doctor was like I mean that
that Doctor ended up being like a key uh
like witness in the Michael
Jackson um what do they call can say
Waldman Waldman Dr Walman no what what
do they called those um maybe I can't
call oh my God no no a a
um a what is it called when you bring
somebody just CU they're an expert in
the subject Court expert witness yeah
thank you so he like put an expert
witness in that Michael Jackson so like
but at that time in
2014 like he told me straight up like I
don't know man like you get off
methodone by weaning off a methadone I
don't know you're going from 220
milligrams to nothing I don't know
what's going to happen nobody knows
what's going to happen I'm GNA throw
some stuff at you and we'll see if it
sticks but my guess is is buckle up this
is going to suck and that's literally
how he laid it out for me I was like
enraged because I was like oh my God and
and that
was that was I don't know the
I I had done very well working with my
hands doing plumbing and construction
and stuff but I was so drawn and I think
about it now and I think about that
like I can't complain about working in
treatment because I definitely chose it
because being in treatment I met the
weirdest people there was this kid that
was the first second first no first or
second night I'm there like a bunch of
adult children he comes in he like sits
down on the couch he's he's sitting
there and he's like oh
yeah noodle groovin noodle groin noodle
groovin where they're like still sober
but still like [__] the mess got them
like and I'm like
and's I remember that dude there was
this cholo that was the the night like
guy and that was the shift that was
working and I he falls asleep and still
bugging and I look over and I'm like oh
that guy spilled a little water on his
pants or something and then I look back
over and it's growing and he's just
pissing was he just sitting
up he was happy see when people be there
there man I'm telling you man he just
and I'm like and I'm sitting there and
I'm just like h p PE PE cuz I didn't
know what to like do like hey my brother
used to [__] people up dude when they
would P test him if he didn't like you
he would do it all taking a [__] oh yeah
you would be like he'd be looking him in
the eyes taking his [__] and you UA
people like when they would you like I
would do all sort of stuff like I would
do what I called the wiy the Poo so I
just drop my my ankles and put my shirt
under my chin then we need go UA for
them or um yeah there was a couple times
was because I didn't dislike them I
guess I was just like I was like a
really good I really wanted what they
were selling because they always brag
about you being such a good client yeah
i' gotten to the point where you have
FES on you bro you FES on being dead
sounded awesome yeah I just couldn't
pull the TR that was bad like I didn't
have the courage or that not courage
that's that's a terrible was your
darkest point that point for sure right
is that is that your darkest point I
mean there was another time in Hawaii
where he was on benzo's too he was on
benzos and methadon like he wasn't
eating he was literally wasting smell
bad he was wasting my dad is not the
type of Dude to ask for help for [__]
for [__] he's just not that guy and he
came to me came to me didn't call me he
well he called me and said come to the
house and said you need to go to your
little brother Patrick's house and get
your brother Kenny and put him in
treatment cuz I'm not going to watch my
son die he said go now go get my kid and
he said it like that go get my kid go
get my son like don't let my Su die at
that point and we went me and my buddy
Max went over there and grabbed him and
he he agreed he greed he was like all
right dude all right for sure and I'm
like bro this is bad you're bad you know
I mean at that point it's like why not
like got him carton of smokes and like
it was like cool and the place was
really nice it was like at the top of
what moholland and Del L Canyon lurel
Canyon it was so nice dude no no no no
no you're talking about the hills that's
where you worked I'm talking about in
malib was
virgin Canyon sorry en it was beautiful
man yeah it was a beautiful had a water
slide and [__] [__] it was a cool place
but he was a crooked [__] that's
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that was my
introduction so I got I got my first
internship after 90 days sober into that
program and that guy ends up getting
like I don't know 157 years for
insurance fraud and sex what he was
doing was he was paying the policies
that he was
billing you know what I mean he would
act like he had some Scholarship
Foundation he was billing for dead
people he was doing he was bad he was he
was I mean when I heard about the sex
stuff I was out you know I went I
branched out and never well that's when
he went from ad all to meth dude this
dude used to hold the microphone over
his [__] head like this and talk to
it [__] the it's a systemic problem
oh you know the families are the problem
you know it's your dad look down and be
so high on Aderall dude I thought he was
on the and he had danger every day bro
his shoulders were covered in danger he
was such a weird dude he wears Penny
lovers with the pennies and no socks
yeah and then he have like and then a
black shirt I was always like why why
don't you wear a white shirt he's
covered to like a ginger always half
bald he was almost completely bald I
don't know where the dandruff was coming
from this is the guy that owned the
treatment center that we're talking
about that Jack said was run by Guy
somebody with um like less than good
intentions at first though at first it
seemed like he was trying to like help
people by robbing these [__]
insurance companies and everybody was
down for that everybody and that's
because insurance company's been robbing
everybody in this country for how long
mean our turn we come from the 90s right
so the 90s remember the guy on the news
that blows his head off with like the s
h you remember that on the 10 freeway in
front of his dog that poor dog yeah at
nitu 1999 like they're all doing these
dirty things and so we're I'm uh you
know an adolescent coming hearing about
these These are the relative cultural
stories that I'm hearing is that
insurance companies are paying doctors
to not run tests for certain diseases to
make sure they don't have to pay out and
stuff and that really is I mean but we
were you know what bro we were so
[__] poor because of this [__] you
know why because my dad no matter what
we had medical insurance and he paid for
out of his pocket Kaiser yep so like a
third of his [__] income went to this
[__] to so seven kids could go to the
hospital if they need to and he was the
last [__] to take you to the
hospital you know he's like yeah walk it
off you know rub some dirt on that type
[__] my head's bleeding you're fine
you're fine like butterfly stitches you
know
and paid a third of his [__] income
basically to keep make sure that if
something happened to us we'd be okay in
America seven kids like doing it by
himself as a painter painting houses
this dude was
like just [__] it's not easy to the
medical system is set up to where like
that shit's [__] bro we should I'm glad
I'm glad he robbed them fools [__] it
sexual how many rehabs are are are leg
genuinely trying to help people wow
that's all
the one I that the no recovery is for
sure yeah I mean
100% it's hard because the thing is is
that 90% of them believe they are you
know what I mean it's like with anything
you you make concessions right so when
you're running a treatment center you've
got the the clientele right you've got
the reason you got into the business
right help the addicts then you've got
all the staff on the payroll and their
families rely on this job to eat and
live and so you know like people make
small concessions and there's people in
it for the money though dog that are
just of course it's also just straight
like criminal so like criminals there is
there is I mean also talking about like
during the so Obama passes the the
legislation the Healthcare Reform Act
Right and it pushes insurance companies
to cover things right because
pre-existing conditions so mental health
is now covered yeah so you can't not
cover somebody for being a drug addict
ex and at that time everything on the
open market even policies that pay very
very well yep so yeah there's there was
lots of I believe um is it like that now
it's a lot better no wait what yeah bro
what open policy pays for treatment no
what open market policy P I'm talking
about the the treatment centers actually
keeping their nose clean because they to
there's no value in it the the insurance
companies have so it's almost like I
look at it like Star Wars it's like they
got [__] down super raw like in in the
in the90s and the in the 2000s really it
was like it was like the 2008 to like 16
you know they're charging five grand
ripped and [__] they're opening their
own Labs they're they're like well why
am I paying this lab and they're
charging them to gr I'll just open my
own lab I mean these places are making
millions and millions and millions of
dollars and then there comes a time and
I call it the Empire Strikes Back and
the insurance companies just [__] go
no more yeah they're over it they're
over it right now dude FBI task force
comes out um you know making sure for
all this types of fraudulent right
they're going to make sure nobody gets
treatment right like of course like the
feds are on that to make sure nobody
gets better right is it getting cleaned
up yeah but it has to be because the
insurance companies won't pay but now
the insurance companies went from like
we were paying
$220,000 for this guy to go to a
treatment for you know 60 90 days this
is crazy to like those same insurance
says now pay $500 a day or something so
now it's
like honestly I don't like if there's
like the luxury places there's there's a
niche right yeah yeah they take cash
somebody's there knows
people that's that's the only way to run
a luxury you gotten in with the
entertainment industry you gotten in
with the music industry you gotten in
with some sort of high paying industry
that has incredible
uh no well they don't need money just
money right I I personally think and I
guess I I I've it would take too long to
explain why I believe this I personally
believe that uh private out of network
um treatment will everybody's talking
about how we need more treatment I think
it'll be cut by 80% in the next 20 years
for sure for sure you're going to have
you're going to have it'll be public or
not at all you're going to have 100 ,000
for 90 days just give it to me up front
you're going to have medical Y and then
you're going to have [__] places that
like just keep you got to keep it real
real inexpensive and think about how
like he's saying that in the next 20
years and what do we in the middle of
right now people dying on drugs epidemic
and the insurance companies are doing
everything there's not an open market
policy that can get you private [__]
treatment now that means you could not
go right now with no matter how much
money you [__] got if you went if you
went and got the best policy that's
available to you right now i' I'd give
you a list of like two places and that's
only do your work or your parents it's
because I've got a decade of experience
and so I could give you maybe two places
that are privately own I mean I remember
people calling me and uh there was a
short time where I was doing the
admissions process of it good at that
yeah yeah and that's why you have to
love what you do cuz if people are like
you're in it for the money it's like no
I could make so much more money doing so
if you can talk somebody into going to
one place instead of 45,000 other places
you can talk them and anything what do
you think the solution is to this whole
drug problem that we have in the country
prob the world take the phones away I
mean people have to like be around each
other and [__] yeah me personally um I
me it seems like the drugs are coming
from Mexico and China yeah and if you'd
asked Mexico this is a culture problem
if you asked Mexico and China would they
love see the United States just buckle
and fall oh [__] yeah and we're already
eating ourselves from the inside yeah
fenos killed more people than the War I
guarantee you bro yeah and then that's
and and so that's what I was saying that
it takes all like most people have all
those factors going they got a
biological a physiological sociological
and
existential attachment to a substance
and sociological for sure you know how
many people have you heard that goes and
gets college degrees puts themselves
into debt and they can barely get get an
entry level position right at some sort
of company you've got that being one
thing me personally I I have boycotted
not boycotted I'm not like standing and
going in circles with a [__] sign but
I've made a personal decision not to
interact with social media and that's
directly a response of what I've
seen because from when I first get sober
to what I see the people today you're
not just detoxing them off of drugs and
alcohol you're detoxing them off of
their
phone like these day like
you're the phone is always like it's
it's one out of every group it's always
and I'm going at the lowest
level it is a drag out balls out fight
to get their phone obviously you can't
some places do I worked for a place
where it's like just watch them real
closely and they get it for 4 hours a
day after the first three days that's
more of a luxury setting you know I've
got my girls they pop out I've worked at
many places where I wear tailored suits
and I ran multi-million dollar um you
know places that have heated pools and
queen-sized beds five star I went there
he got me in there I need that place was
SI you get five star meals and stuff
like that they catered every day every
meal most of the places I've worked went
bankrupt they just went bankrupt they
expected last year's return from the
insurance company but insurance
companies hold out too don't they want
yo they'll audit you this is what
they'll do all right there somebody's
doing cost analysis at at the insurance
companies and they're saying okay these
people have now pulled x amount from us
and they're continuing to pull this much
amount we to plug this hole bro audit
them an audit can take up to a year that
means everything they owe from that
moment until the audit is over over
they don't have to pay it and so you
what'll happen you get H hit with one or
two of
those it'll shut you down that's it I
mean I mean a lot of these a lot of
impatient places from what I've seen are
barely hanging on yeah and so and
they're fighting like like the thing is
is like and the insurance company switch
it up on you right so that you have to
like it's almost like in order to catch
up you nearly have to do something
illegal to just keep your doors open
because Insurance compan supp to change
the rules you know so how do and when
you asked me like how many good places
versus bad places it's hard because
there's so many people that have all the
good intentions in the world but they
start making little concessions to keep
the jobs for their people you know what
I
meaning these people are doing really
well you know uh you know I'm going to
break a regulation here or there and
then sometimes like anything I mean I
think it's a human condition you can
incrementally talk yourself pretty damn
far just like I incrementally went
from successful and happy to flies on my
face like that like you know what I mean
like I I I a lot of people fall from
very far and it's and it goes both ways
it's kind of like a mirror of itself
right so you've got the substance abuser
that incrementally will allow themselves
to become less and less human right that
their brain is going to especially when
it comes to dopamine and all the ways
that the human brain works is going to
slowly talk it has to justify what
you're doing right you don't just go
from millionaire to bum you know that's
never an
overnight you know um condition
you know that's that happens
incrementally and the mind justifies it
and it's the same thing for people that
end up running and I'm not justifying
any place I personally won't attach
myself to a place that's not Kosher
right but um but I understand when some
of these people and they truly
care but they they've put everything
they've got on the line now we're not
talking about the early 2000 stuff that
was like dude that you got a guy that's
sober for 30 days and his dad's willing
to bankroll it for 30 grand and he's
making 30 million a year you know when
they turn that tap off those guys went
quick you know but I can see how
somebody goes from you know I work for a
place it was 20 21 beds almost
$25,000 in in advertising most of that
just to be relevant on Google
$25,000 a month you've already got you
know $10,000 lease or or house payment
or whatever you've already got $10,000
worth of DWP or more in gas bill company
food you've got quadruple or five times
that payroll you've already got all this
incurred cost
right so just like the attic
incrementally will justify themselves
falling lower and lower a person that
got in it for the right reasons can
incrementally talk themselves into
waking up one day they woke up one day
and they were on the street well this
guy woke up one day and he's a triple
felon it's a it's like a mirror image of
itself so I I see how it happens and
especially when you're in it
and you're seeing how dirty the
insurance companies
play everybody around you starts
thinking like yeah [__] them yeah you
know what I mean bet automatic but
there's FBI task force that are not
playing any games and then you're you're
under licensing under the state that
you're in and then when people say
there's no good treatment centers in
their states it's because California why
is it we're like the second densest
treatment populated
state area our state area in the world
well it's because of how it's
regulated dhcs the Department of
Healthcare Services doesn't play around
if they find any problems issues things
they go they talk to the clients they go
through all your paperwork they find
you're acting up and they will close you
down it's not like they're easy on it
it's just easy to in comparison to a
place that requires a judge to sign
for you to open a treatment center in
that state
so a lot of people flood to California
or Florida because it's it's a it's
easier in comparison to their state or
you know like you've only got so many
people in Arizona it's an epidemic right
but again you're you're
compartmentalized you got your your Rich
luxury places that's a niche you've got
your private out of network places
that's a niche you've got your in n work
places that's a niche and then you got
your um medical Medica or subsidized
places right that's a niche and then
you've got this other one don't even get
me started on
nonprofits a
nonprofit you can look it's like public
record nonprofits can be like okay so
the Los Angeles gave us you know $10
million this year uh Los Angeles City
gave us 10 Los Angeles County gave us
eight the state of California gave us
eight uh and the federal government gave
us another 10 and uh we spent $8 million
and we lost 28 I know the math didn't
make sense on that because I wasn't
keeping track but they'll just like say
we lost it I don't know so right you go
so like I don't know and it's public the
Pentagon so it's kind of
like the answer is as difficult as you
know like how do you solve the homeless
problem yeah that's it's a
nuanced it's a very nuanced issue yeah
because hold on before you go down what
what is the okay I'm GNA prompt you on
this the shadiest thing you've ever seen
somebody do to get another person in
treatment that really [__] with an a
full
culture so what I'm saying is you
remember when then body Brokers were
getting people in based off of their
bloodlines oh that was its own health so
body broker like body broker came out
the movie and stuff and it became well I
came to I was working yeah yeah yeah
it's called body broker oh [__] and so
that really kind of
like put a spotlight on it obviously if
they're coming out with movies like it's
not as easy to do you know what I mean
because when the Federal Bureau of
Investigation wants you they'll get you
you can get warrants for Taps and all
that you know but uh oh yeah
so
somebody that
incentivizes a patient to go to
treatment so they for what but but they
they also like these kinds of the ones
that help them get insurance like they
they basically do an illegal sh some
illegal [__] no no I'm gonna get to that
so so I'm just going saying the general
what a body broker is is like the
general concept of it is that they
incentivize a client to go to treatment
so this person is no longer somebody who
stood up and said I want to go to
treatment they they've given them an
incentive whether it's money drugs hotel
rooms promises um promises a lot of
promises I remember in the late when you
get past 2017 2018 it's like a drag out
battle because now you've got the
treatment center not paying the body
broker and the body broker not paying
the client or they are paying but this
person's not paying and everybody's
talking about it and yelling about it
and like it it's a disgusting disgusting
thing it's human trafficking really so
what he's talking about is I F I knew of
a guy who his hustle was so filthy bro
he couldn't pump in enough people by
brokering them so he gets with a
lab that does Native American blood
cards because Native American Health
Insurance haven't they had it hard
enough oh yeah no no no no no wiping
them off the planet wasn't enough so
like obviously what's left of the Native
American like people have privileges
because I mean they got it so dirty for
so long I'm such a fan of American
History North American history between
1700 and
1900 1900 and 2000 let not I don't want
to get off of what they were actually
doing all right so he gets with and they
start cutting fraudulent blood cards so
it said you were in a tribe so then then
that person joins the tribe then they
get tribal Insurance then they send them
to the treatment center and then the
treatment center right so [__] up and
then the treatment center pays that guy
but that guy but what does a pre tribal
Insurance end up doing in the end stop
sending people to [__] treatment yeah
so the tribal insurance or what they do
is like you would see these same tribals
insurance that were paying these
astronomical amounts were I mean it'll
don't get me wrong a couple of places
almost claim a couple of big names human
I think Blue Blue Shield of California
has been super for all sorts of [__] but
I I think Blue Shield of California
Health I think they were ready to claim
bankruptcy like with it was bad it was
cross sh was [__] they got [__] up
in in the L so they they they pulled out
of the open market so if anybody wants
to know that's not a drug
why you can't go to the open market and
get a fabulous po
policy it's because they raped him yeah
the the the substance abuse industry
definitely got them pretty good and now
they're getting everybody back but the
problem is is that that affects
everybody but like yeah what he was
talking about that guy when I met him uh
it was like back in the day when we were
like you know
um I was such a polarized person cuz I
like I I would have own
businesses in one hand and then you know
go out with the gun that as the same
person it was weird but
like there was there was some I still
there was sometimes where him and I were
around true sociopathic pillars and you
can when when you're in their presence
you feel it there's something happens I
there is something always something bad
happens too dude that's why I believe in
spirituality there is something about
human connection between two people
that's non-quantifiable at this time
there is something about it you talked
about it when you talked about
authenticity there's something that you
feel when you're with something and when
you're with the sociopath you got that
vibration off thems that is buggy bro
not you your B you're it's visceral
right and that was the same thing when I
got around this guy and he's just
scrolling through his phone like this
look
look at all the [__] etas
and and he's talking about
insured clientele bro hey stop stop stop
I love you I love you I love you I love
you dog he's crazy [__] but I got
that same feeling off of him I'm
like this guy's wrong half those people
are probably dead today you know and we
laugh so we don't cry honestly and
that's that's how I've I've dealt with
um of our life most of our life yeah
yeah yeah But continuing to work and uh
I mean you I've been threatened my
life's been threatened working in
treatment so many times people threaten
your kids and [__] [__] your baby it's
just yeah yeah kill you I'm gonna follow
you home [__] up your car I'm going to
do you know cuz
you're in control of their
phone well yeah that's one but you don't
give my phone back I'll rape you Jesus
bro this person you're a person you're
coming into this situation your only
means of coping is taken away yeah and
it's being replaced with like it's kind
of like when
like on a smaller level it's kind of
like when it's like you see somebody
that's like 600 lbs and you're just like
Jesus Christ man what happened like dude
just get up and walk around the block a
couple of times and take take it easy on
how much you eat you know but for that
it's not that easy but you know they
need Fork cck andit yeah but for that
person like they can't stop and so if
you just took away their food that's
kind of the same way it feels to the
addict is like I I feel like it it's
like food water procreation right we all
have these natural drives to do what we
to to to be human beings and then at a
certain point if you cross that
threshold when you're an addict it gets
on the list and so now it's no
longer it's no longer a prefrontal
cortex problem now it's in your psyche
now it's like it's like telling yourself
oh food's not readily available right
now don't be hungry water's not readily
available right now don't be thirsty you
know I you're married don't want to [__]
that woman whatever it may be like those
are ins
comparable no no because because food
water procreation those are intin my
human like instincts you know what I
mean and when it makes it on there it's
like even when the person doesn't want
it they hate you and them for not having
it because it's like something Primal
instinctual in you is
saying you need that and that's
why some of the
smartest and greatest
politicians that could have ever been
just never made it cuz they couldn't
hold their [__] together long enough
because they can
manipulate I mean they
manipulate if you think about it it's
like you never had a job in your whole
life you're 27 years old and if you do
the math you've done $100 a day for 365
days you have hustled up like you know a
million you know what I mean like you
Millions put money to do dope and not
all of them most of
them most of the people well no a lot of
the people that I met they're not like
pistol whipping people they're not
crawling through Windows yeah you know I
mean Jack they're like he said he was a
snake you know yeah they're they're
hustling money not now out of people one
way or another people I deal with every
day yeah oh bro bro I was going to ask
you like down there in an Open Air
Market like that yeah where like where
is the money coming from the outside
because it seems like so like when you
get loaded when you start getting doing
drugs right you isolate from people that
don't do drugs and you stay around
people that do do drugs you stay by
yourself so everybody down there is like
[__] up so where's the money like do
they just kind of spange out a little
bit some change and then bring it all
back lots of boosting oh L lots of lots
of people having sex with with right but
so people are coming down there and
bringing the money in yeah yeah yeah
check checks out yeah yeah yeah that's
and that's that's what I've seen there's
like an range of I mean the amount of
sex that goes on down there for money is
people don't talk about it but it's it's
like it's it's everywhere Jesus yeah men
and women drugs dude oh metham is a hell
of a drug only men buying it but
there're men and women selling it yeah
it's crazy many isn't as big out here as
it used to be I mean guys hide it a lot
more it's a it's more it's more L harder
like when they're getting sober it's a
lot harder of nut to crack if that's
been a part of their story um women are
a little bit more open about it I think
that they find a way to it's not so
humiliating yeah yeah um but yeah that's
that's that's I've heard so
many different things
and it's a very difficult business to be
in it's a very difficult business to run
and and I
think everybody would like to see an
answer to the substance abuse
problem but I think somebody once said
on on on some show I'm a fan of like
everybody wants Arizona taxes with
California benefits and that's the
problem you know you you that's and and
I'm I mean from my perspective as far as
I know there's no better alternative
other than fixing the system that we
have I don't think that there's some I
would take
operation caring there's not some
International or like some space outside
of uh you know I remember working in a
lot of people used to call in admissions
being like so can you come get my son
and we'd be like yeah we we we can
provide transportation but we need to do
a pre screen oh no no no he doesn't want
to go and I'm like ma'am that's called
kidnapping there hey do you remember
when Patty me and Mario got got like
dude all right let me finish this out
sorry that's enough for us to bite off
today yeah oh we're done I love you good
job love you too brother thanks you guys
that was amazing yeah yeah perfect
awesome thank you
Mark